hello everybody this is Luka as you know
I am here with my friend Amir he is he's
a polyglot he has made some very
interesting videos on YouTube speaking
some of his languages so without further
ado I would like to talk directly to him
he's here so high I mean how you doing
something well wait how's the weather in
Kazakhstan well it's it's been cold
lately yes sir oh yeah plus two plus
three so soon but it's cold but not as
cold as I thought so it's okay so could
you tell us a little bit about your
cultural and linguistic background and
share with us some further details on
the countries who lived in or she had
and the light oh yeah sure I was born
and raised in Almaty
which is the former capital of
Kazakhstan I used to speak Russian and
exact until I was six thereafter I was
enrolled in elementary school where
everything was starting in Russian and
of course as I was progressing I was
speaking more Russian town as well yeah
the only foreign language I studied at
school was English but the truth is I
started taking it seriously only when I
turned 16 I did my bachelor degree in
Canada I left got exam when I was 18 I
spent last 4 years in Canada where I was
studying Bachelor of Business
Administration program and I was
studying other languages by myself at
the same time because it's family cut
big responsibility but cuz ask you if
are boost yeah social any ocean models
now you know Kazakhstan is nice for
Kazakhstan Agra my sternum is totemo
play dota
resource of aspersion impartial start by
astronomer ischemia is demolish it a
sturdy mama would put it was running
priests are she Bierce poor because of
commotion Chile's to natural solutions
to animals actually to the pie effective
Buddhism Kirsten pathogenetic emotions
drama genetic Mira Pablo she is a
mishmash y con air Toco Toco / HOF
cuñado
Yan dou UJ blunderstone esto el cuñado
there's my pistol air vision um I can
see now in second exam exam understand
you a social news Avicii my business
from la pajcha tiny but still a stoker
science cool tourists remain so the
opposite or stone like every source to
be juice can finish list you can use
resolutely honey
Percy skimpy this new gem cut already
point you will buy his custom suit made
out of dope in siesta speedy departure
get the money he can see between decent
salute do-yeon main open Punta Mita
guarda k2 Xian PO Li la la una persona
king of a deeper live a linguist upon
Oliphant Shana photometry position banda
banja a lima Tal Afar
like classic autumn Honda keep wanting
were partly either there will be any
Supra to to boost our beliefs in
opportunity I joke okay I saw something
I already explained we may be generated
then colleague way rooster a Kazakh
sano-sama do lingua Kate giving power to
the Pico parent Rwanda de ninguna man
say yo parlo Italiano sanchez de esta
llamo a tempo proto jz y no tre parlo
inglese a Tresckow arezzo so impaired
ando Activa meant a chain sha Turco
windy
shamone Volia div para una lingua
assault akkada chambo ma non SI casa con
el Turco Jack a par loca sarcoma
collision AZ mijo tha s copier le cose
no Adobe na questa passione record o
molto bene que cuando era adolescente NV
on Papa Mia Rico lotto libro tsuki Amato
comas moses somali cave oh dear a
natural kappa cheetah ester you mama
Quinn d.c Tata Kelly persona que quiero
no capacity dear a conjure no Sarah qual
giorno della seta mana Sara yacht
Elettra prevent iya ya al gringo say yo
esto tiene llamada mousse Mon Ami a
Fresnel molto me a personal neighbors no
no le persone a que era makup a CD y
para la cual call came in Guney questa
yo SE que eres una persona a foot pole
yo yo yo no puedo aprender observe and
es en dolo team s Li Busta puede lugar
grande resultados estos Bella quizás ah
gracias al tanto si las fiestas di
Milano no cinemas oh Sh Olga modest
apart a moody seafood elf you pono ok
poozer esta manera pasa en dole Okemos
le gusta uno dos uno por el amor lejos
no see no se siente mas mas animado
pues para me eran las más entrevista zkn
con los cuales IKONOS tetra no raise no
toes poor miss envision a scenario que
lo que ellos dicen después de del de los
partidos no de teléfono yo
mira cuenta que ellos no son omen del
del for bono sino también habla de sus
presenta mentos de todas
here to hear it okay into lasciviousness
con con ellos - we have a new dementia
cosets following help was so gentlemen
O'Reilly Ellijay a mean name boost on
the future affordance is for therapists
a their electoral relationship yeah
although his most design is deep and
goes another sheet solution and Nelson
videos T to afford a yarn of you to
permit us from them from tighter than a
I commanded [ __ ] gentleness isn't art
especially was Moses ollie our Felicia's
does an intranet soon this to start the
better that but he see as their
bandwagon finger on his water dish
problem you need to sternum are not more
off medicine through to learn money
would alpha into that you on - OH - what
a hot this outfit was be done how to be
me I'm giving me muscle tone that's this
analytic afoul of mesh so ya sign now
that's compliment from dear come on
crowd intimacy honest an on this dish on
the artists most month one begins again
yeah sheesh Lorber I'm fine horseman say
she needs to read osorb in the bottom of
the fish - yes yeah a positive edge to
multiply Invicta Cosima
you do lose design of - aged a spacer
shred first reading one semester like
Muslim high distance event the urge to
learn once a month alleged scientist
designer house raha Robeson and yeah was
it seeing item the mailman gates English
and it's a list this thousand is again
they are society give us a starting well
this one was good soil scientists Argos
manatee it's Spanish Baja
very finish writing mmhmm yeah
understood say 2000 where he obviously
did
on a culinary balladeer to predicament
not which attorneys each other the more
delicious a flight back sesame not to
conclude who it on the domaine de
Longueville water he will see to do one
dedication professional constitute
oriented I think in strong opposition to
the rocky papasano
saying anti so most cities Josie
synthesized in kitchen area her history
driven from the terminal easy to G good
decision usually that mr. solo can add I
wanna yeah c'mon pick you know made not
just after to be a proposition baton
because important moral issue a solution
yeah because her cousin to the sample
which easy
voila Milan Kalyani Synology subscribe
paragraph where you started in
continually visited conclusion this
exactly okay bye
II say kuta mementos economist open the
finish was commercial Ecco fast you will
recommend Berea para para couch be
pianist - nice Agora would understand
English - mr. song is cut up into Jewish
immigrants so
fellowship area the come on Camila
monitor always pronounce Christian three
Amish fur still sterile buh-bye Yahoo
well mouth proper nostril bush nation
normally working if you could move on me
emphysema
but I will that but especially a formal
presentó replenish
come on cooling unit out but I wish very
much faster without machine and three so
ever that character turns three stay
incomplete story somewhere I see me only
so back to English now for the final
question I want to ask you okay you're
learning Chinese as well as Turkish but
are you interested in other languages
are you feature projects because you're
still very young so I can imagine that
your first four languages you're going
to learn on the language I'm pretty sure
I just want to ask you which languages
you have something in mind already or
well definitely I think people who
enjoyed learning languages are are
always curious are always you know
experiencing this hunger or for new
things as for me I would love to add
some exotic languages down the roads and
for me no this would be Japanese and
Korean I think those are two languages
I'm really interested it okay so let me
know thank you very much for this
multilingual interview thank you look at
thanks behind me thank you Tom